c'est un projet unique en france
léa les écoles des éco-activités possède
désormais un plateau technique
ferroviaire sur le campus
d'aubergenville qu'ils sont maîtres de
voix vont permettre de former les élèves
aux métiers de la signalisation de la
caténaire ou encore de la voie ferrée il
nous apporte des compléments aux
informations et des supports aux
formations des jeunes et des moins
jeunes puisque nous allons commencer par
la formation continue pour le plateau
ferroviaire qui sont absolument
indispensables pour que lorsque les
personnes rentrer dans la vie active ou
reviennent alors qu'il soit parfaitement
opérationnels avec ses quatre complices
en ile-de-france les écoles des
éco-activités accueil 1700 étudiants
pour des formations qui vont du ceap et
au master 2 particularité ces formations
sont conçus avec les entreprises
il faut former des jeunes qui peuvent
entretenir réparer les voies de chemin
de fer il se trouve qu'il y a un très
grand besoin en ile de france à raison
du grand paris on va construire 200 km
de voies ferrées supérieur on va doubler
le métro parisien
donc il ya un besoin important
[Musique]
un projet de 2,8 millions d'euros
financés à 40 % par le département des
yvelines et son agent d'insertion
activités ici vous avez un beau cercle
vertueux de l'investissement public qui
va générer de l'emploi
cet emploi va permettre de l'insertion
et tout ça parce qu'il y aura une
formation
c'est le cercle parfait jusqu'en 2021
sur le site d'aubergenville près de 300
apprentis et stagiaires seront formés
aux métiers du ferroviaire